so this hand is doing that that's it be
easy this thing you have to gather now
[Music]
bring them into your
better tighten up boy
save percussion not like this you want
to hit the center there we go Kristen
shot and I'm just doing the same thing
so he's doing you and he has to hit the
percussion oh you're gonna pick just
keep your grip push push knock me down
that's your only child
[Music]
you're worried about landing on them who
cares
yes that's it just it's just football
slammed on let's go you have too many
jobs don't go this way go that way don't
land on you know just the same one
attention to the attack yes I said go so
this thing way by my shoulders are
relaxed so I'm not gonna push him squish
my shoulders
they're very mushy and then if I push
him you can feel them tight to play
right so I keep my shoulders very
relaxed
okay keep squeezing them like sharp
okay so what we're trying to do is learn
a different mechanism so you have to
stop using the old because that one's
engrained itself okay the one we're
using it's a kokyu projection if I can
set my shoulders I'm going to get a
muscle isolation which operates as a
blockage for my the percussion that I
want which is down here in my puddle my
tension is a blockage from you to that
okay so we'll do it drill and we'll have
them be close you don't have to worry
about the IT partner okay so I'm gonna
go here and I'm just going to leave
everything and bow into that come on the
sides as you can
so I get it in place you're all fine
sorta up to here now I'm not going to
push with them that's going to stay
there I'm going to lock everything and
I'm going to do a static operation of
the mechanics okay it's easier to do
static operations at the same account
but it is the same attendance we're just
not using it in terms of repercussions
so when I'm here like this I tighten all
that right it's tight and then I'm gonna
bow and when I bow I bow into his weight
so I don't follow me here and going to
bow into the heavy part
and once you feel comfortable with that
you're going to get that Moochie
shoulder because it has nothing to do
with it has nothing to do with anything
so you keep pushing it and you bow
keeping that form okay so one and I
relax I release that but I walk
everything else everything else is
locked and I'm just going to bow in ten
feet okay let's try that drill